Recall the reduction example.
The work is linear, and the number
of transfers, is at least n over L.
Now let's analyze a concrete
algorithm to see, whether or not,
we can achieve this lower bound.
Now here's the natural thing you would
write in the conventional RAM model.
That is the one without the fast memory.
It maintains an accumulator s, and
makes a sweep over all the elements,
accumulating them.
Now you need to modify this procedure,
to think about when to move data,
between slow and fast memory.
Now, the variable s is easy.
You can just assume that it starts
locally, in the fast memory.
It's the same way you might
treat any temporary scalar or
local variable in your favorite
imperative programming language.
For my pseudo code,
I've just declared s to be local.
I'm doing that just to be clear.
Most of the time you can ignore
these kinds of local variables.
Now what about the array X?
For simplicity, let's assume that
little n is, much bigger than,
the size of fast memory.
Let's further assume that X is
aligned,on an L word boundary.
With these assumptions, let's transform
the program, to make slow and
fast memory transfers explicit.
Yikes.
Let's start with the outer loop.
As with the original algorithm, it steps
through the elements of the array but
it does so,
one block of size L at a time.
Next, there's the computation L hat.
This mumbo jumbo just determines whether
the block that starts a position
i is of length L, or
a little bit smaller.
It's a detail.
I just wanted to be clear.
But most of the time,
we'll ignore this sort of detail.
Next, there's
the assignment to little y.
This is an explicit load or read,
from slow memory, to fast memory.
Notice that it requests at most L words,
which is one block transfer.
Now, since little y and
S are both local to fast memory,
the processor can execute
this innermost loop.
So what's the work in the number
of transfers for this algorithm?
The work is just the same as this
conventional algorithm in the RAM model,
that is, it's just theta of n.
Here's the number of transfers, it's
just the ceiling of n over L, hopefully,
you can see how this falls out,
very naturally,
from the structure of the code.
So how do these compare
to the lower bounds?
Why they compare very well, indeed.
Before moving on, I want to make two
remarks about what you've just done.
First, I realize that was a lot of
painful detail to do what must seem like
a really simple analysis.
We will make simplifications, as we go,
but I wanted to start by just
being clear about exactly what has to
happen under the hood in this model.
Now, my second remark.
Yes, I know about caches.
They're those fast memory thingys that
the hardware manages automatically.
In fact, there's an awesome OMSCS
class that covers their design in
a lot of detail.
While caches are very useful,
what you'll eventually see
is that they aren't sufficient
to guarantee high performance.
That is why we're discussing an explicit
model of locality, like this one.